[Applause]
[Music]
June is about to close out but before
the summer gets even hotter we've got
some big swords evil bears and cheerful
marsupials on the way those aren't all
from the same game although you could
make it happen with one of these and
more on that later for now don't forget
to hit that subscribe button to get new
releases delivered to you every Sunday
leaping into the current generation is
Crash Bandicoot and Sain trilogy whether
your favorite crash game is the original
cortex strikes back or warped you'll be
able to play all three rebuilt for the
ps4
that means the levels have the same
layout as the originals but with totally
new animation and sound so the trilogy
should look and play even better than
you remember a pretty great way to
celebrate the series 20th anniversary if
you ask me you can celebrate for
yourself on Friday June 30th but until
then let's all remember the days when
you could put on a suit and yell at your
competitors through a megaphone hey
plumber boy moustache man your worst
nightmare has arrived back up you're
stuck monokuma is a lot less cartoony
than crash and the evil bear is still
very much a threat in danganronpa
another episode ultra despair girls well
at least his clones are this spinoff
takes place in a city overrun by killer
monokuma robots and it's up to komaru to
end their threat of despair unlike the
visual novel gameplay of the main series
ultra despair girls is a horror
adventure game komaru will have to use
her hacking gun to shoot enemies scan
the environment for clues and solve
puzzles if you haven't picked up the
original Vita version you can now join
her on this journey on ps4 and PC on
Tuesday June 27 so have any of these
games been up your alley so far think
you could make something better
now you can prove it with RPG Maker
fests no coding knowledge required here
just use the interface to create your
own stories worlds in combat and make
the RPG you've always wanted
there's no need to hog the hero's
journey either you can upload your games
for other people to play and then grab
the free RPG maker player from the eShop
to play some of theirs you can start
creating and sharing on 3ds on the 27th
speaking of Nintendo systems it's always
a good time to bring up Zelda the master
trials is breath of the wilds first DLC
pack and it's bringing a ton of new
content to Hyrule there's new armor like
the Corrick mask which will help you
find those cute little tree creatures
more easily and for more of a challenge
you can try out the new hard mode you
can track where you've been with the
hero's path map feature and get back to
a warp point of your choosing via the
new travel medallion
but the biggest edition of all is the
trial of the sword an all new challenge
area with 45 rooms to clear completing
this boost the master swords power for
the rest of your journey it'll be
available to download on both Nintendo
switch and Wii U on Friday June 30th but
if you want to see the DLC in action
right now you can check out our stage
demo from e3 let's wrap up with one more
RPG Tokyo Xanadu it's from the same team
behind the east and Legend of Heroes
series but this one is set in a
fictional suburb of the very real
modern-day Tokyo social media and the
Internet play a big part in Tokyo Xanadu
story where a deadly shadow world
emerges from the center of town it all
sounds pretty reminiscent of this year's
smash hit persona 5 so if that sounds
good to you then you can grab this PS
Vita game on the 30th and those are the
hottest games we'll be playing this week
as always remember that release dates
are based on retailer listings and are
subject to change thanks for watching
guys and I'll be back with more games
next week